I'm super excited to get to talk to you
about the show I just finished watching
the first season last night and I think
it's safe to say the two of you play
some of the most badass women on this
show
um
for both of you how familiar were you
with the franchise before you signed on
well in my case I knew about the
franchise of course I watched some of
the movies I played the first game and
then I got to play the last game the VR
one so of course
um like I'm in my 40s I know everything
about Resident Evil I never thought I
was going to be part of the world of the
franchise and I'm really grateful for
that very similar here in terms of such
an iconic franchise there's no world in
which I don't think you can really find
anyone who hasn't at least heard of
Resident Evil
um so definitely watch the movies I did
not play the games however did watch
people play it for me just on you know
YouTube kind of like a twitch situation
um but yeah familiar with the franchise
also lots of friends and family who are
really big fans of either the movies or
the games yeah it is kind of like a
movie when you get to watch someone else
play it I've done that before for sure
yeah when did the two of you officially
learn who you were playing was it
anything that was kind of held back were
you not sure who you were auditioning
for at first or it was something that
you kind of always knew which character
you were going to be
for me I learned uh you know they sent
me the character description so I
basically knew what kind of character
she was I didn't know if if she was just
one of the main
um characters I didn't know at first I
don't know if she it was part of like
this group of villains like I didn't
know much until I read all the episodes
and you know at episode when is when it
said episode eight
the the Ruby reveal of uh I think really
in the future what's happening with
Evelyn six six is it six and then when I
read also that big twist at the end that
has to do with uh big uh older Billy and
Evelyn I found that really interesting
because I was so not expecting that and
I think that's a really interesting
twist to the story so I think for me
actually I did initially go out for a
different character but I think this was
at a time when they were just in general
auditioning they didn't really have an
idea yet then I remember I got the
callback for Billy specifically and that
was a known thing for me from the get-go
when I did get the call back they did
give me more information
um they were kind enough to send me I
don't know if this is like the third
time now but like at some point they
gave me the scripts
um I think just two scripts one of Young
me that I could understand in one of one
of the audition scenes I was doing
so I did know early on
um
what was going to happen ish but I
didn't understand like where it was
going to fall in how exactly it was
going to happen I didn't know everything
that young me had gone through yet did
not know about the ending
um so there was a lot of mystery uh but
yeah I did have a good idea actually
they were very generous Paula Evelyn is
a character who holds so much power for
much of the season but there's so much
more to her than just being kind of the
figurehead and the top of the umbrella
chain what did you want to emphasize in
portraying her not just as a powerful
woman
pain that's what I wanted to
uh I wanted her at one and I still won
uh fans of of the the show uh to see her
as a wounded person you know that is
trying to gain some control of her life
and she wants to be recognized and
respected and just couldn't she's she
makes all the wrong decisions of course
but I just want people to connect with
the part that I connect to her which is
the need
to be important the need to be seen the
need to
um make a difference I think she's she
is she has a huge ego and she really
wants to make a difference and she
really wants respect and recognition and
to belong and we all have those things
in like different you know Doses and uh
the fact that yeah she's a sociopath or
you can see her as a really bad person
but I I find really interesting with
when we as actors can manage I don't
know if I'm going to manage I don't know
if I did a good job but I wanted to make
her human and I wanted to to have those
moments of humanity where we can see her
pain and we can see that she doesn't
have the control that she wants to have
all the time I mean for what it's worth
I think you did a great job of capturing
those complexities to her character
um when it comes to the character of
Billy we have the same character who's
being played by two different actresses
both of you having to take her on it
very different points in her life
um I know you said that you had been
given the chance to read a script kind
of you know of her from a younger age
um were you able to see Sienna's
performance at all like were there any
opportunities that you had to kind of
see what she was doing and then would
then in turn help to develop your own
portrayal like anything that you took
from her and tried to reflect this is a
very long-winded question I'm sure no
but yeah yeah
um no thank you for the question
um 100 so I did get the scripts but I
came in later obviously in the episodes
there for later on to set
um so Sienna had already kind of
established young Billy you know it's
one thing like reading about it and kind
of making your own assumptions for your
older Billy it's another two it's kind
of almost like a blessing to be able to
watch like a couple of Clips they gave
me a couple of clips of her
um for one of the scenes or a couple of
scenes that she had done
um I also was in contact with her before
um since we knew who was already cast
and I remember when she got her hair
done I was like oh my God is that the
hair we're getting like are we I know
it's like years apart but I think that
was something that we kind of
that I also wanted to have in common
with young Billy
um that I also pushed for and I'm happy
they did it
um but yeah in terms of character I
think there was elements of her
personality that I kind of saw in myself
or like an older Billy as is because I
mean ultimately we pour ourselves into
these characters and I think that Sienna
and I had a couple of things in common
and therefore even though their
personalities have or Billy's
personality has evolved at the core it's
the same person right they just choose
to they just have different thoughts
maybe now
um or choose to do things a little bit
differently or navigate the world
differently
um but ultimately it's about a girl who
loves her sister who had to go through a
lot of turmoil or has also like
a loving but also a complicated
relationship with her sister and her
father
um yeah it's definitely a lot of
complicated family relationships for
both of your characters you know I would
say
um I know you probably can't say much
but given that we do kind of know there
is a little bit of a connection between
your characters at some point in the
future what can you teach for fans about
about that expect the unexpected let me
tell you in every sense yeah it's hard
not to
yeah I would say just like not all the
characters that seem to have control
have control I mean you can always
expect
that
the
power
shifts like in life like power shifts
even if you don't expect it I mean at
least for my character like that she's
she's holding on to this power and
control and I really think that that
applies to life right when you hold
tight I have a phrase I mean this phrase
that I love hearing of like hold it
Loosely because if you hold that things
like really tight you're probably gonna
at some point like lose all control and
that that applies to Evelyn so I feel
that the control theme is is really
important for both of our characters
and then I guess the only thing that I
will say to is which is cool which I
didn't think about but it's true
Evelyn gets to have or actually no you
Poe I get to have the experience as
Evelyn with young and older Billy and
let's just say that the twist is Stark I
think that's definitely fair to say um I
am all out of time but thank you both so
much for taking time to talk about this
show I'm really excited for everyone
else to get to see it you both do some
really great work together and apart so
looking forward to everyone else getting
to see that too thank you so much